I will leave it there we're gonna move
on to this it could be a big week for
news out of the Supreme Court the
Supreme Court is about to release two
rulings that could shape American
politics for years to come the justices
will decide this week whether to let the
Trump administration ask about
citizenship in the 2020 census and
they're also expected to decide whether
congressional district maps in North
Carolina and Maryland are
unconstitutional because they are drawn
in to politically slanted a way CBS News
legal Anas LAN legal analyst and law
professor Kim Whaley is the author of
the new book how to read the
Constitution and why Kim good morning
morning so for people who are not legal
eagles watching everybody move from the
Supreme Court they hear about these two
cases the question about are you a
citizen potentially on the census and
the drawing of congressional maps
what are the stakes for the average
American well there's a lot of forces
moving away from individual votes
counting and corporate money other sort
of interests actually deciding our
democracy so these particular cases
could one the citizenship could either
favor or disfavor counting heads based
on race I think that's the question that
is if people have to answer citizenship
they might not answer the census at all
there'd be fewer heads in that
particular state that state might get
either fewer votes in Congress and or
less money so that's number one
gerrymandering is a big one because
that's on both sides of the political
spectrum both Democrats and Republicans
carve up districts and ways to make sure
that they continue to win regardless of
what the voters want and the Supreme
Court has so far not stepped in with a
standard for to test when something is
too carved up and when something is
sufficient so we have to see if they're
gonna do it this time so if two carved
up then what you're saying is people's
votes will not matter as much as they
should or people's states will not have
the representation they should yeah the
idea is that even if you are a Democrat
if you're in a solidly Republican
carved-up district that wins you know it
along a river and some bizarre way you
will never ever flip that district to
the other side because of the way it's
carved up it will just automatically be
a shoo-in for that prior candidate I
want to pick up on what Toni was saying
about the voting because you write in a
crumbling democracy the bow
really matters do you think we are
living in a crumbling democracy is that
what you're think that you know justice
Douglas talked about the twilight of
democracy and when it happens it'll be
slow it's not going to be obvious and
we're in an era where we have increasing
power in the office of the presidency
not just under Donald Trump but for
decades now and a Congress that's not
really putting up some stop signs and
it's human nature if there's if there's
a stop sign but there's no consequences
you'll blow through the stop sign and
eventually we have too much power in
government that's gonna hurt the
individual and so people have to think
about taking their government back and
the best way to do that is at the ballot
so let's talk about this with regard to
Iran because the president says he
doesn't need congressional approval to
strike Iran what does the Constitution
actually say the Constitution is in
conflict here Congress has the power to
declare war and to raise armies and to
support armies but the president has the
commander-in-chief power and so scholars
differ on which the chicken-and-egg
which comes first does there have to be
a declaration of war before you could
send troops in the battle or once they
create troops the president's in charge
and as effectively at the end of the day
Congress has allowed presidents over and
over to send troops into battle so again
without a stopgap without a stop sign a
ticket on the on the windshield saying
you know president we're stopping you
here essentially that kind of power has
amassed in the office of the presidency
I remember in 2016 people were keeping
their constitution in their front pocket
this is a little big to fit in the front
pocket maybe the back pocket you can
tear out the back we don't want to mess
up the book thank you very much
Kym Whitley for joining us this morning
how to read the Constitution and why is
on sale wherever you like to buy your
books